My oncologist suggested that I increase my B vitamins to help build back my red blood cells following chemo last year. I also take B liver capsules.
My multivitimate, myocloride, I take one, rather than the suggested one, and also has B vitamins. For a few months, I took extra Bs, your encapsulation be complex.
I opened the capsules and took one half or one third of them, and my latest lab did not show any improvement.
Excuse me, my latest lab did show some improvement.
Last week, Zoom call you mentioned that cancer patients don't need too many methyl groups. Hopefully I got that right. Yes, you did.
If I am in remission, does that still apply? Would you suggest taking extra B complex or not?
Yes, I said, if you are in remissioned and you are dealing with low hemoglobin or especially if you are dealing with high homocysteine levels.
Homocysteine is a product of the misdiadiene cycle and homocysteine is a metabolic midpoint metabolite, meaning that it isn't necessarily, it's kind of a bad guy in two higher concentrations in our body.
It's supposed to stay in two higher concentrations because it's supposed to be converted to downstream metabolite that is less dangerous and it's dependent upon some B vitamins and folate in order for it to convert.
So a person that is deficient in folate and some of the B vitamins can have high homocysteine and that's the most dangerous thing for heart disease.
So if your homocysteine is high, then you do need to take more B's and you can even take some methyl-bethylated B's for that sake.
Certainly, if you are in remission, you don't really need, this doesn't necessarily apply to you even if you don't apply homocysteine, you can still certainly take lots of B's.